When we started to farm,
I was swept up in the beauty of learning to make food from scratch.
It makes sense why I soon fell in love with idea of a family milk cow.
I was making my own butter, cheese,
ice cream, and yogurt.
As I began to explore this world,
to cook and invent, I needed a way to share these products
with more than just friends and family.
I needed a dairy. So two years of planning,
and then an additional two years of construction,
and we finally did it. And soon,
we'll be sharing these products with all of you.
So for date night tonight,
Daniel and I snuck over to the dairy.
The temperature was perfect.
Little floor Joe was giggling,
and the cows were gorgeous.
It's the world we created,
and I couldn't love it more.